Namo tassa bhagavato hara-harto samma sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
Majjhol Buddha, pienamente risvegliato.
So, I'm going to talk about the extraordinary ability of the Buddha to teach.
What I will talk about tonight are the extraordinary abilities that Buddha had to teach.
So I have no doubt he was a very charismatic person, but that would not necessarily make him a good teacher.
I have no doubt that he was an extraordinarily charismatic person, but this in itself would not have made him a particularly skilled teacher.
So he had the ability to teach large groups, monastics, nuns and so on, lay people, and adapt his teaching to them.
And he was especially acute when talking to individuals, catching their moods and opinions, and through various techniques was able to correct their views and practices.
He was particularly skillful, he was particularly capable when he spoke to individuals, to individuals.
He was able to capture their moods, their opinions.
And thanks to different techniques, he was able to correct their opinions, their points of view and also their practice.
Now, he wasn't always successful.
A character called Dandapani went away clicking his tongue.
It didn't always happen.
A certain character called Dandapani
he walked around shaking his tongue, that is, expressing his disapproval.
So now the usual way he discussed subjects was to first listen fully to what the other was saying, then he would repeat back to them what they had just said to make sure they both understood.
So the way he usually dealt with
And he would correct the person by a Socratic method of questions and answers, yeah?
After that, he corrected the person with a process of questions and answers of the Socratic type.
Now, once the Buddha, once he'd expressed his position, he would then restate it again clearly and usually he would add a metaphor or an analogy, as he would say, because some people understand better that way.
So, over the next few Buddha celebration days, I hope to take one technique after another.
Nelle prossime giornate di celebrazioni del Buddha vorrei affrontare, trattare una tecnica dopo l'altra.
And use a discourse to illustrate it.
Utilizzando per illustrarla un discorso, uno dei sutta.
So this is the shorter discourse with Malankya Putta.
This, specifically, is the short speech with Malunchia Putta.
It's an example of how he would guide intellectuals away from conceptual, speculative thinking, abstract and metaphysical ideas, and he'd guide them towards practical wisdom.
And he wasn't shy to call them fools.
This speech is an example of the way he
guided and distanced people from an excessively conceptual and speculative way of thinking, by distancing them from too abstract and metaphysical ideas and instead by bringing them to a practical type of wisdom.
And he had no fear of calling them fools when necessary.
So Malunkhya Putta was the son of Malunkhya, who was married to an evaluator of the king of Kosala.
And he became a Samana, a wandering ascetic.
When he heard the Buddha speak, he took ordination under him, but he didn't attain liberation till he was very old.
Divenne dunque un samana, una sceta errante, e quando ascoltò Udil Buddha parlare, prese l'abito sott'Udil con lui, però non ottenne la liberazione fino a quando non fu molto anziano.
So now, while Malenkiaputta was alone meditating near Savatthi, in Jeta's grove and Arthapindika's monastery,
he had been considering the subjects the Buddha would not answer.
One day, while Malunkyaputta was alone and was meditating near Savatthi in the forest of Jeta, the monastery of Anathapindika, he was thinking about the topics to which the Buddha had not answered, the questions to which the Buddha had never given an answer.
Now, these were the sort of metaphysical questions of the day, and he came to a decision that if the Buddha didn't give him satisfactory answers to his questions, he would lose confidence and leave the Sangha.
It was about questions, questions that were raised, metaphysical questions of the time.
And Malunkyaputta came to the decision that if Buddha had not given him satisfactory answers to these questions, he would have lost all faith in him and would have left the Sangha.
So, in the late afternoon, Malunkyaputta came out of retreat and went to the Buddha.
He bowed, sat down to one side, and told the Buddha of his thoughts.
So, in the late afternoon, Manon Khyaputta left the retreat and went back to Buddha.
She bowed, sat down on one side, sang a song, and expressed her thoughts to Buddha.
Venerable Sir, while I was alone in meditation, the following thought arose in my mind.
These speculative views have been left undeclared by the Blessed One, set aside and rejected by him.
Namely, the world is eternal or the world is not eternal.
The world is infinite or the world is finite.
The soul is the same as the body or is the soul one thing and the body another?
And after the death of the Tathāgata, that's the Buddha, does he exist or after death does he not exist?
Or after death does the Tathāgata both exist and not exist?
Or after death does the Tathāgata neither exist nor not exist?
Venerable Lord, while I was meditating, the following thought came to my mind.
These questions, these speculative questions, have been left unanswered by the Blessed One.
They have been abandoned and rejected by Him.
And they are as follows, namely, the world is eternal or the world is not eternal.
The world is finished or the world is infinite.
The soul is the same thing as the body, or the soul is one thing and the body is another.
And then again, after death, after his death, the Tathagata continues to exist, Tathagata, the transcendent Buddha, or after death a Tathagata does not exist, or again after death a Tathagata exists and does not exist,
o ancora dopo la morte un tatàgata non esiste né non esiste.
Now, if the Blessed One knows, then let the Blessed One declare that to me, and I will lead the holy life under you.
Se il Beato lo sa, allora che il Beato me lo dichiari apertamente, io condurrò la vita santa sotto la sua guida, sotto la tua guida.
If the Blessed One does not know, then it is simple for one who does not know, does not see, to say, I do not know, I do not see.
Then I will abandon the training and return to the lay life.
Se il beato non sa, allora è bene che colui che non sa e non vede dica ben chiaramente non so, non vedo.
In questo caso abbandonerò l'addestramento e tornerò alla vita laica.
Ah.
Well now, Malunkiaputta, did I ever say to you, come Malunkiaputta, leave the holy life under me and I will declare to you whether I have answers to these questions or not?
No, Venerable Sir.
Well then, Malunkiaputta, have I ever told you, come Malunkiaputta, lead the holy life under my guidance and I will declare to you whether or not I have the answers to these questions?
O Venerabile Signore.
And did you ever say to me, Venerable Sir, I will lead the spiritual life under the Buddha only if the Buddha will declare these things to me?
No, Venerable Sir.
E mi hai mai detto, mi hai mai detto, Venerabile Signore, condurrò la vita spirituale sotto la guida del Buddha solo se il Buddha mi dichiarerà queste cose?
O Venerabile Signore.
So now the Buddha makes sure they both agree as to what has been said.
So it seems to me that I did not say to you, come Malankya Buddha, lead the spiritual life under me and I will declare these things to you.
And you never said to me, sir, I will lead the spiritual life under the Buddha only if the Buddha will declare these things to me.
In which case, you foolish man, who are you and what are you rejecting?
So, it seems that I did not tell you, come, malunkiaputta, lead the spiritual life under the guidance of Buddha and I will declare these things to you.
And you never told me, Lord, I will lead the spiritual life under the guidance of Buddha, only if Buddha will declare these things to me.
In this case, stupid man, who are you and what are you rejecting?
Now, if anyone should say, I will not lead the holy life under the Blessed One until the Blessed One declares answers to these questions, they will still remain undeclared by the Tathagata and meanwhile the person would die.
Ora, se qualcuno dicesse, non condurrò la vita santa sotto la guida del Buddha finché il Beato non avesse dichiarato le risposte a queste domande,
These would remain undeclared by the Tathagata and in the meantime that person would die.
Now the Buddha uses this usual technique to support what he's saying with an allegory or a metaphor.
And now the Buddha uses, as usual, a technique that would serve as support
to what he was saying, thus using a metaphor or allegory.
Suppose, Malankyaputta, a man were wounded by an arrow thickly smeared with poison and his friends and companions, his kinsmen and relatives, brought a surgeon to treat him.
And the man would say, I will not let the surgeon pull the arrow out until I know whether the man who wounded me was a noble, a brahmin, a merchant or a worker, whether he was tall or short or middle height, whether the bow was long or a crossbow.
What kind of feathers the shaft that wounded me was fitted with?
Whether those of a vulture, a heron, a hawk, a peacock, or a stork?
And what kind of arrowhead it was that wounded me, whether it spiked, or razor-tipped, or curved, or barbed, or carved-toothed, or lancet-toothed?
Oppone in Malunchia Putta che un uomo fosse ferito da una freccia densamente cosparsa di veleno.
and that his friends and companions, relatives and colleagues, brought a surgeon to cure him, and that the man said, I will not allow the surgeon to extract this arrow until I know if the man who hurt me was a noble, a brahman, a merchant or a worker, if he was tall, short or of medium stature, if the bow was a long bow or a balustrade.
What kind of feather was stuck in the arrow that hurt me?
If the feathers of a fan, or of an iron, or of a falcon, or of a peacock, or of a cicada.
And what kind of arrowhead did it hurt me?
Sharp, with a razorhead tip, curved, crocheted, with veal teeth, or in the shape of a spear?
All this would still be unknown to that man and meanwhile he would die.
So too, Malonkhiputta, if anyone should say, I will not lead the holy life under the Blessed One until the Blessed One declares on these questions, they would still remain undeclared by the Tathagata and meanwhile that person would die.
All this would not remain known to that man and meanwhile he would die.
Allo stesso modo, ma l'unchia putta, se qualcuno dicesse, non condurrò la vita santa sotto il beato affinché il beato non si pronunci su tali questioni, queste rimarrebbero non dichiarate dal Tathagata e nel frattempo quella persona morirebbe.
Now, the Buddha goes on to say that it's not true that the spiritual life cannot be led unless these speculative views are answered, and he reaffirms his position.
Then Buddha continues by saying that it is not true that spiritual life cannot be conducted without such speculative questions finding an answer, and reaffirms his position.
Whether such views are answered or not, there is still birth, there is still aging, there is still death, there is still sorrow, lamentation, pain, grief and despair.
And it is the destruction of these, right here and now, that I prescribe for.
That such questions find less answer, there is always birth, there is always aging, there is always death.
There is always pain, lament, sadness, affliction and despair.
And it is the destruction of these things, right here and now, that I prescribe.
Therefore, Malunkya Putta, remember what I have left undeclared as undeclared, and remember what I have declared as declared.
Pertanto, Malunkya Putta, ricorda ciò che ho lasciato non dichiarato come non dichiarato, e ricorda ciò che ho dichiarato come dichiarato.
And why have I left them undeclared?
Because they are not beneficial.
They do not belong to the fundamentals of the spiritual life.
They do not lead to disenchantment, to dispassion, to cessation, to peace, to direct knowledge, to awakening, to nibbana.
That is why I have left them undeclared.
And why have I left them undeclared?
Because they are not beneficial, they do not belong to the foundations of the holy and spiritual life.
non conducono al disincanto, al distacco, alla cessazione, alla pace, alla conoscenza diretta, al risveglio, al nibbana.
Ecco perché li ho lasciati non dichiarati.
And what have I declared?
There is suffering and unsatisfactoriness.
There is the origin of suffering and unsatisfactoriness.
There is a cessation of suffering and unsatisfactoriness and there is a way leading to the cessation of suffering and unsatisfactoriness.
E cosa ho dichiarato?
C'è sofferenza e insoddisfazione.
C'è l'origine della sofferenza e dell'insoddisfazione.
c'è la cessazione della sofferenza e dell'insoddisfazione, e c'è la via che conduce alla cessazione della sofferenza e dell'insoddisfazione.
That is what the Blessed One said, and the Venerable Malamkhya Buddha was satisfied and delighted in the Blessed One's words.
Questo è ciò che disse il Beato.
The Venerable Manu Khyaputta was satisfied and delighted by the words of the Blessed One.
So this discourse shows us how the Buddha generally taught by first listening and then probing and then finally stating his teachings and his use of metaphor.
This discourse shows how in general Buddha taught first by listening, then
and then finally affirming his teaching and finally the use of the metaphor.
And he would not be drawn into hypothetical, metaphysical or speculative discussions.
They were simply not conducive to the spiritual aim of liberating oneself from dukkha, suffering and unsatisfactoriness.
The Buddha tells us there is a limit beyond reason.
Reason and logic simply cannot go.
and which can only be transcended and realized by direct experience.
Il Buddha ci dice che c'è un limite oltre il quale ragione e logica non possono andare e che può essere trasceso soltanto e realizzato solamente grazie a una esperienza diretta.
And finally, the reason he refused to answer questions about himself
What happened to him after he died was that these questions invariably arose from some idea of a self that would either exist or not exist, exist and not exist, and neither exist nor not exist.
And finally, the reason why he refused to answer these questions about himself, the Tathagata, that is, what would have happened after his death,
was that this type of questions arose invariably from some idea of a if that would have existed or not existed, or has existed and not existed, or has existed or not existed.
Very good.
I hope this little talk has been of some assistance, that it has not caused confusion.
Spero che questo piccolo sermone sia stato di aiuto e che non abbia creato confusione alcuna.
That by your careful practice and reading you will be liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.
E che grazie alla vostra pratica, alla lettura dei discorsi, sarete liberati dalla sofferenza sperabilmente prima piuttosto che dopo.